of course I'm on tour I'm driving a
Porsche over the floorboards over the
farm points way in the floor tourists
getting abortion in the divorce at the
same time to hear and support him
look what I'm planning planning I'm
planning to do all this while you're
panicking and you're looking at staring
at mannequins and I'm gonna sanic is
trying to get up a plan against all of
the planet cos Santa can fan fan fan
against what on Avantika Santa can
Hannah in a Cabana
you're gonna come I'm in a Cabana in the
Janet I'm gonna Cabana chant in order
stand a banner or you don't got to stand
on your land a stamina your lack of the
Sam I don't want your divorce an amorous
affording them in a portion of flowing
ports while I'm wrong torrent using way
too many napkins napkins laughs kisses
chappie you use the chair sticking their
hands while I'm packin flapping around
like a babkin slamming a baby declaring
a champion damn
in the locker room if somebody looks at
me I make [ __ ] straight heterosexual
eye contact with them I don't [ __ ]
around look at Mike if they look at my
[ __ ] I look back I go that's what
happened baby that's what God gave me I
got that [ __ ] pat-pat-pat [ __ ] I got
that PAP [ __ ] dude I don't you know I'm
not covering my [ __ ] enough in the
locker room I'm not covering my [ __ ] in
a locker room dude that's like an M&M
lyric covering macaque in the locker
room who covers the CAC in the Lankan
room I'm not the kind of guy who come as
his character in his black you got to
seem a little penis Amina Sabina Dina
go home do not mix me yeah but again
okay black dude he rubs everything for
real none of that rhymes do not mix me
yeah but again okay and his lack of room
and everyone's like whoa how does he
find everything that rhymes he doesn't
dude you never found a penis to mean
it's Dean Dean that's a penis only
nabina the meanest in the marina
Williams you think your penis being a
Serena Williams Serena Williams doesn't
run with penis you know forth
but an orange Trump you're like alright
I guess
who's dumb iPhones gump or annoyance
Trump but I'm thinking what a man is
gonna come from a character lack of room
penis to see my penis between wings and
dude and [ __ ] 45 year old white dudes
are like that's [ __ ] so good how 45
years old is it too like Eminem and and
think he's the best rapper
I'm not dogging on Eminem dude the guy
is one of the best rappers of all time
it's just so funny to think of a 45 year
old guy named like Derrick that's just
like oh man Eminem is the greatest
rapper right like that you know what
that is that's so la Kenyatta dad to
think
Eminem is it so it's so dad from
Pasadena to be like Eminem is is he's
great because he's a lyricist like it's
some of his stuff is poetry some of his
stuff is poetry you know a guy a white
guy who's 45 that has beige hair and
wears Dockers has said that a million
guys like that have said that literally
a million I don't I'm not really into
his when he's talking about penis and
Serena Williams but you know that [ __ ]
in a locker room
since I use them across my opponents you
ever hear that evidence on my words I'm
weapons I'm a Christian my opponents
opponents the bonus the bonus I make the
bonus the bonus the bonus and my bonus
and show me some bonus alone as the
Domus my dong dong dong as a bonus and
on them I'm getting bonus on the pony so
Jonas upon bonus these ones and weapons
I never show no emotion even though I'm
angry right now what I mean when I says
I don't show emotions is a note crying
even though one got songs in my crap
basically a hypocrite in just like even
though I'm crying handle myself like
gonna gag doesn't disagree
[Music]
what does every time always sound like
he's under a truck I got bad luck to the
drunk on that junk junk the gun some bad
luck my warns and weapons but they don't
help me now Wow get this trunk on me
before up trunk
I'm thunk to bending some lat it's a bad
luck I'm gonna be crying but I never
shown almost is even normal I like the
game district man look cheery literally
I pick up my phone and Siri says I don't
know how to respond to that and it
that's what it says I never I didn't hit
her button she's just like what the [ __ ]
are you doing what are you doing I think
you look going cuz I'm bored
I'm on a world tour doesn't matter cuz
don't born born and I got my pockets
fanuc Aziz these fan where song ever
we're a song of all time this is a fun
funky fun a funky episode dude
well I'm
I'm playing in a hand trick with Danica
Patrick I'm sinning that's it McKenna's
fantastic design system Fox's designs
the foxes what I missing into the boxes
a whole bunch of boxes right in my
garage with a bunch of large cars the
started apart a bunch of uh cars there's
no hearts Cabrales swerving swerving in
an emergency lane with cars for New
Jersey